hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen today I
have my best Katara casual Katara
cosplay going on because I am doing the
live-action Avatar The Last Airbender I
didn't want to do this one for November
but I put up a Twitter poll and you have
to follow the politics of Twitter and
this one the poll I loved the show when
it was on I haven't seen it since it
originally aired but I watched all of it
I've heard terrible things about this
and I also have been in the room while
this was playing so I've seen what it
looks like like I've glanced at it on a
screen but I've never seen it I haven't
seen any of like any any of it I haven't
seen it I just I was in the room as it
was playing I just want to get that out
there like if people will find out and
then I just all my credibility is lost
what credibility I have none apparently
let's just do it I guess
[Music]
okay so it wasn't as bad as Garbage Pail
Kids and it wasn't as bad as Super Mario
Bros but it was just not what it should
have been the show is so incredibly
incredible and wonderful and good I just
said it in the intro but I haven't seen
the last airbender cartoon since it came
out so I might forget things during this
reaction video but I mean from what I
can remember it was way more fun than
that also I love a night I love him I
love his stuff I love a stupid style I
love his dumb cameos in his own films I
just loved it I loved the village I
loved sighs I loved football news fifth
element sixth sense that's the one loved
it lady in the water terrible I'm like
the devil hilariously bad
I thought the visit was super fun and
entertaining and so this was just really
weird like what an odd project for him
to work on right why who gave this to
him it was like you know what you know
who will do great the science guy did
you see lady in the water this will be
great I did not like the parts where the
pure water nation is white people and
then the Fire Nation is not white people
why was that the choice that's so and
not I also thought that like the traits
of the characters from what I can
remember like I said it's been a long
time but the traits of the certain
characters that you're watching like the
leads are so dulled
down like in a way but where is the fun
where did where did the fun go Sokka
biggest example of that is Sokka Sokka
was like this goofball funny guy like
trickster like always like upset like
just us
were animated than this character who by
the way couldn't act to save his life
I'm so sorry but the acting in this was
terrible I feel like they got a lot of
names wrong - I remember him being
called Sokka and he was Sokka
in this and egg I remember he was called
egg right not owned first thing I wrote
down is whitewashing and then the next
thing I wrote down is few complaints
about me complaining about whitewashing
down below they'll be there they'll be
there so you see Aang I'm gonna call
Ming sorry if it's wrong but you see
Aang in the water frozen and then they
melt it you see Appa like yes okay at
least Appa is here and then he's like
not at all in the movie at all also what
did they do to his face
Appa is supposed to be cute and magical
and magnificent and he looks like a
weird toad gorilla and it just it's not
right okay moving on
you see Zuko and he's like bring me all
of the elderly just I know why but like
it's just a weird thing to exclaim I
want to knit and eat creamed corn
so like reserved and I feel like that's
coming from and night shamalamadingdong
who is like Charlie down and we're gonna
it's gonna be really Chu
that's the vibe I get from it he's just
like shushing everyone the whole time I
I just wish I could be a fly on the wall
during filming of this it just seems
like it was a boring process which is so
tragic death Patel
that's Dev Patel he's so young oh that's
why it's cute because Deb could tell
she's a great actor om night oh you did
him dirty they capture Aang Aang escapes
and then egg finds out that all of the
people that he knew and loved have died
he was in the ice for a long time and
he's the avatar
and it's so boring and I don't care at
all you get the first teen that has a
little bit of action it's like oh I
thank the Lord above there in this
earthbender camp and you get to see a
little bit of earthbending and you get
to see airbending and firebending and so
they escape this is kind of where the
revolution starts and they start like
banning together and going against the
Fire Nation and it's like cool I wish
there was a hundred percent more venting
in this movie you barely get to see any
of it and before you do there's like a
hundred thousand like arm gestures that
they have to do and it's like it works
in the animated series because it's
animated does it really work here
because I actually don't know what the
actors backgrounds but it doesn't seem
like these actors have a lot a ton of
experience maybe I'm wrong it didn't it
didn't read well so the Fire Nation
captures a again for the third time so
far and he escapes again for the third
time so far I guess yes penis hair but
somebody had told me about that before
and so I was I was looking out for it
but it just really shines like a beacon
of hope see it like an hour and 15
minutes into the film and you're just
dying for anything that's worth anything
and then you get peanuts hair so at
least there's that angus is training to
be a waterbender now she's got air down
and you meet the the princess never in
any film has there been a more awkward
couple ever
ever they're so awkward and they develop
this superfast connection but they
literally it seems like they met each
other on set and that one of them like
picks their nose and like why sit on the
other one they were like alright no film
being loved if it's like then like
they're just wrapping it up at this
point there's 15 minutes left
Aang is captured again he escapes again
the fire could mean commander guy kills
the moon spirit and then princess gives
herself to of the moon spirits the moon
spirit
back and then egg uses the ocean to show
them the power of egg and they defeat
the Fire Nation
the last thing Tyrone is defeats the
Fire Nation and then whoa Zucco's sister
comes in they think they're gonna get a
second movie hilarious no way no way no
way
they must have filmed that scene first
and then they were like well we already
felt we might as well just put it in
like there's no way they'd film that
whole movie and was like no but like I
feel good no way the only saving grace
was penis hair damn I did guitarra hair
I should have done penis and your video
has been flagged for removal but you'll
be bored and sad and wonder what the
hell they did to soccer yes a slow head
shake at the sad optimism that is the
cliffhanger I like that but it was more
like no why are you next question why
can't they act Oh shots fired
why can't they say anger correctly on
thug life but wonder how sokka's actor
kept getting work after Twilight he was
in Twilight a moment of silence for
acting a lot of people bringing up penis
hair don't look at me I voted for Kazaam
next week I'm doing Kazaam or I'm doing
troll - thank you so much for watching I
will see y'all next week with a more at
least fun movie maybe not good it is
November but it will be at least more
fun All Right see y'all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you